[Musica]
60 milioni e troppo 101 sono i cittadini
italiani
di questi 4 milioni e mezzo hanno una
disabilità certificata sì mi è capitata
perché non sandolo ognuno di noi sa
qualcosa che non sapere ognuno di noi è
un sito comunica con i padri cup ad
esempio
alzi la mano chi almeno una volta non ha
saputo associare intanto i nip oppure
nella pasta anche io ma io non usino con
oppure a qualche di noi al supermercato
moussa emozioni pocomeno facendo finta
di sapere se siano maturi oppure no
oppure alta sembroni la propria strada
non arrivi a nuovi mac pro erano rimini
che sembro io quando è poi prendere una
roja nella mia vita
poi strizzare in 20 pietro non è un
ceppo il mondo al fondo liquori sanità
oppure non saper aprire nemmeno una la
ripropone senza la pesca pole e spezzare
gli spaghetti o lascia le mie chiavi
della macchina mentre una macchina poco
prima per scopi un tempo lari e poi c'è
questa fare l'ha fatta senza effetti
apporti che manca la carta igienica non
sapere parte dare nemmeno smart da
nemica non sbaglia io so serpe lancio
saranno né promossi tutto quindi a cuneo
dopo indicazioni
e poi fumogeni sanità gregari quindi
sono i vestiti che poi nessuno nelle
minuti ad esempio noi uomini non
sappiamo mai provare le cose nella morsa
nelle donne oppure sono menti chiamo gli
anniversari fulani matrimonio
fidanzamento nel primo marshall e lei
vuole sapere neanche quello nel primo
bacio o facciamola capi ogni tanto fuori
o meglio voi io l'ho sostenuto che
almeno una prova
iniziamo la enorme tasse remi onde
intriganti e quindi france tra i luoghi
comuni sulle mie donne stupide sapevo
qui nella macchina e poi a sorbirsi i
luoghi comuni sulle donne al volante
pericolo costante
questo sono le disabilità che mi sedini
quelle fette da fuori romeni ma sono
comunque importanti ad esempio capitare
immunis e non esistere
oppure essere utile nella classifica
micologo allora parlando a noi 8 milioni
amendoni disabili ma da se e solo se
porta 6 milioni in su canini cosiddetti
normodotati comunione vuol dire che la
disabilità
il quarto in modo purtroppo per fortuna
è un momento per guarda una minoranza
della minoranza degli italiani nel pot e
non conosciamo testamento e non
appartiene a noi andiamo un po alla
lontana molto perché dobbiamo parlarne e
non mi hanno ai caschi molare empatia
per il nostro ero sviluppa da torte e
possiamo così uno terzi nei panni negli
altri amici
conoscendo qualcosa che prima non
avevamo
ma come possiamo farlo
ad esempio con l'amore sono solo
percorsa montino autobus
questo è un articolo che lo stress nel
2004 in funzione un appello alla
politica un po prima sapone o ricevo
questo mi crede nel pelo non perché sia
unione che voglio innamorarmi su un
autobus o treno il compleanno la ragazza
nei miei sogni come in un film romantico
o richard gere e julia roberts dato che
se per me khenifra nir e lo mette in
cascina
siamo noi che da tutta questa differenza
la capiscono il comunismo in tutta
italia e anche oltre
per esempio è una troupe della bbc che
insomma mi sembrava strano che un
ragazzo fosse costretto a lanciare una
campagna per una cosa che per loro è la
naturale e meno tono ministro emozione
quell'enorme la prima telefonata a mia
nonna non niente mi stato la missile o
plan umane un'intervista a una sera
umane
stai attento e nemmeno animista
sequestrarlo in meglio niente o nei
finali e tranne coni questa finale e la
ninna contro lo avrebbe pagato il
riscatto dopo questo per dire che ognuno
di noi a partire dal clan si sa lo sa la
mattina a 1 m potere quello di poter
essere un tipo ingranano nel motore del
cambiamento pur polare possiamo
attraverso quello che facciamo quello
che diciamo ogni giorno attraverso
quello che stiamo influenzare gli altri
che provare a rompere quei preferenze e
poi di stand e gli sprechi che poniamo
veramente ovunque ogni come 4 c'è il po
di qua un po come i paesaggi artisti
adesso è il tuo volta ero al ristorante
con la mia famiglia semifina la famiglia
era e senza nemmeno guardarmi vinifera
mio uomo
il mic annoni con la festa il allo
sportello non usa il mio marmorini sì
soprattutto se si arrabbia
di nutrirmi data maniera ministro
coltello michele nel vino anche quello
del nostro ente come minuti
peccato che non sapeva che sono nato con
una mina me di salinità dalla nascita
presto un nuovo esterno e quindi fini
verdini e fusi
oppure quando impone negozio il promesso
la commessa non si rivolgano ai anni in
carrozzina ma all'accompagnatore cioè
una mini sta però poi quando fai da te
né i soldi mi chiede sempre a quello
giusto fra i knew ma mi fermo ceramica
ognuno di noi vittima né pregiudizi
tanto un po in maniera inconsapevole
molti mucche cattiveria ogni tanto quote
per litro l'abbiamo minuti una scelta
che hanno sono loro le mie nonne che poi
io sono nato in una famiglia con un
pochino fabio di sette anni
grande ipo due metri sportivo bello
porta marmi tommy trovo affascinante
perché arrivato nel club infine con i
parenti né ogni volta seduto accanto a
lui arriva il momento della sla social
un anno una nonna a lui sa nulla
la fidanzatina poi non lo parlo allora
la scuola
notate qualcosa non è bene poi essendo
le cose non sono migliorate olio
all'unica nell'amore
quando ti sposi e a me allora nelle
ultime ore
oppure dopo mangiato arriva il momento
dei regali e le nonne notti fa il regalo
che fanno la busta per me minimi a
ragazzi come un cus la passano troppo
tempo e lui la mamma inizierà sempre
pieni con questi supporti a nina una
fidanzatina e ameni siamo sempre pieni
con questi insulti
la mm fortunatamente a me scritto il mio
ultimo libro lume carlo anche nelle mie
relazioni sentimentali n'è accorta
capire che il suo mannino non è più un
bambino è resa al portone thing la prima
festa dopo la commutazione nel mio milan
e poi le nostre alpi è la tasto harmonia
norma non ami ma la busta anima i fondi
in mano ce ne mise in testa tutte e due
exit venisse solamente auguri e poi la
stato il regalo più bello che potesse
ricevere era questo per dire due cose su
questo comune può guardare lui messaggi
il primo è che ognuno di noi ha una
disabilità ma sofferto un pò kemalista
militare non esiste se nessuno ha tutti
gli strumenti per poter fare quello che
fanno gli altri iniziato la messa l
sinistra che noi così come vengono
stabiliti a ottenere a milita può
mettersi a disposizione
legnano nella vita come una risorsa vera
e propria per migliorare questo paese
perché dovremmo farlo per soldi per
processo lo mette semplicemente che un
bene abbattere muri e naturali e per
punire punti grazie
[Musica]
va beh
mini con tre minuti allora c'è sempre da
foreign in ultima fase si mette male
l'associazionismo il volontariato
lavorare per gli altri
siamo tutti buoni però ogni tanto una
piccola soddisfazione personale ma non
me ne prendi seminate nel minuti medi
darle posso 5 marzo 2019 crinale
comunitario mattarella mi nomina sala
maniere denari pubblici
qui a quando ministro che sono
buonissimo quindi a quando mi dica che
sono menisco
mi raccomando mi chiede se possiamo fare
una cosa insieme questo popolo che ha
dimostrato tutto normali certa minutara
il simbolo di quella mattinata
chi non ammonire che sono stato
orgoglioso e soddisfatto all'uni cura
nonostante posto lo ammazzo
può il penalista na li lo mostra e lou
nata come poco nell'anno e tra poco dopo
poco settimane sonorità questa
alla mia comunità open source tutta la
bellezza nella cerimonia spazzata via da
un muro nero non è una ricostruzione o
compiute finta ma niente da poco nel
muso nero
allora c'è una terza cosa che noi
stasera possiamo ricordare che quanto al
proprio voglia essere per quanto grande
noi a costruire
il pianista llo sottometterti sempre ci
sarà sempre qualcuno che arriverà
risucchierà come buco meno voto il
successo e non è contato famiglie e
allora tanto vale
nonostante queste spalle strette nella
cartella clinica non settantenne che a
guardarlo però i cantieri o io figura
temi muri alto male ma è aperto il gioco
per provare a costruire qualcosa di
buono per tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]